so for all the same reasons every time
the interpreter visits the middle line
of the car like decorator a new function
will be generated as that car's dot move
method depending on how many cars we
make this could take up a lot of memory
but there's a slight advantage to
putting the dot move method inside the
body of the car like decorator function
now that the dot move function is being
created every time each one has access
to a unique closure scope created when
we invoke the car like function thus we
don't need to rely on the keyword this
anymore
so refactor this code for me try to make
it work such that the move method does
not even refer to the parameter this it
accomplishes all the same things but
without using the keyword this